and it's just all about anish's
experience he used it really well in
those critical moments when to trade
queens off when to defend everything and
i think this is a model game actually
how to handle uh complicated positions
when you're low on time you did it
perfectly there's no tricks here either
i mean this is this is the only thing
that black try to do something on the
king side um you know but i love what
white's doing here swapping pieces off
when your two pawns up
try to swap things off and uh this is
why black's kept the rook on the board
going for
a potential pawn push to create some
openings in the position but it's not
really going to work out yeah
unfortunately
even even maybe
bishop here yeah swap some more pieces
off winning style simon yeah it's a nice
tactic yeah and uh we say you okay it
has happened white has given up a rook
for a bishop but white's bishop is going
to enter the center of the board if the
black rook moves away white striker goes
to the corner and checkmates the black
king and there we go i think ariane
terry he has resigned
about to lose even more material
it's over